so mr. Lyon
yeah how's it going my name is dr. Keith
Lee air house Google all right yeah keep
it up with a football see all right well
I suppose I should get right to it
ah I called you here today because well
there's no easy way to say this I mean
this is hardest part of my day
your parents they're kicking you out of
the house
yeah yep I know I know I know
something like this can be hard to take
in uh but I mean you're 19 19 yeah
you're 19 uh this common for kids your
age I mean really it is I just don't
understand with this as the doing Lynn
medics sadly that's not all your
neighbor while he was backing out of the
driveway this morning uh Larry I think
his name is he ran over your dog peanut
butter
sorry about that I don't understand how
you can be getting this information who
listen Ryan I'm a doctor I know what's
best
well if that's true then I need to get
home that's not all right your
girlfriend is cheating on you a lot more
than that is
okay I know where you're getting this
information I'm sorry I know this news
can be hard to swallow mmm none of the
stuff you were saying can be proven and
there's zero reason for me to believe
you please try not to push your anger on
me I know this is a troublesome
situation everyone handles it in their
own way but you might want to get
yourself checked for STDs your
girlfriend or ex-girlfriend at this
point is um she's kind of a um Oh dick
gargling bag yeah who is he the guy
uh does a Daniel Chi ring any bells I'm
gonna throw up I'm afraid you'll have to
stomach just one more thing two minutes
ago your parents were in a very severe
motor vehicle accident uh the likelihood
of survival in these cases are slim to
none
they're dead a video was uploaded into
the crash did you want to see cool
please stop
No hey however bad life seems right now
it can always get better I mean just
look today we got your results in you
don't have diabetes that's a win in my
book
Oh